has the positive of it this week yeah so  we'll talk to him be a zoom and he's  well hopefully hope he feels better  again he is potentially able to come  back on sunday  ball good job over robinson tapping that  ball alive ends up play  [Applause]  wants the caruso pick there's the blitz  on him but he wanted the foul on walker  oh what a password  the white shadow  he's everywhere  [Applause]  that's the third time it's worked but  robinson couldn't finish the dunk there  is a foul after all of that against  lonzo ball his first there it is right  what's his pass  fake  by the way  slickness right here looking like a  wildcat quarterback  nice place  i see you ac i see ac  does too